Being the 2nd born child in a Royal Family
can be a blessing in disguise.
Nobody expects you to rule, so in a way you
are off the hook.
But sometimes history gets in the way and
unexpected events can bring you in the limelight
and on the throne.
That throne and that crown may represent one
of the youngest, smallest and most peaceful
nations in Europe, but that does not mean
that trouble won’t get in your way.
This is what happened to today’s protagonist,
one of the longest serving and most respected
Royals of the 20th Century: King Haakon VII
of Norway, the voice of dignity against traitors
and invaders.
Prince Carl
At the time of King Haakon’s birth, Norway
was part of a Union with Sweden.
It had an independent cabinet of ministers
and its own parliament, but the formal head
of State was the King of Norway and Sweden:
Carl IV, from the House of Bernadotte, based
in Stockholm.
Therefore, Norway did not have a ruling dynasty
of its own.
The man who would become the King of Norway
was actually a Danish Prince: born near Copenhagen
on 3 August 1872, in Charlottenlund Palace,
he was the second son of the Crown Prince
Frederik and Crown Princess Louise of Denmark.
At birth he was christened as Christian Frederik
Carl Georg Valdemar Axel, known simply as
‘Carl’ by those with shortness of breath.
His elder brother would also become king in
the future, King Christian X of Denmark.
While growing up, Carl would knock time and
again on Christian’s door asking
‘Do you wanna build a snowman?
Or ride our bikes around the halls?’
No, he didn’t.
These guys were serious and received extensive
private tuition at the Palace.
At the age of just 14, Prince Carl began his
training as a naval officer.
He worked hard along the other cadets, and
was not accorded any special privilege.
Carl graduated seven years later in 1893 with
the rank of sub-lieutenant of the Royal Danish
Navy, and was later promoted to first lieutenant.
With that, Carl ticked one of the boxes expected
from a Prince: a military career.
The second box was finding a suitable match,
in other words: meeting and marrying a girl
preferably from another European ruling house.
At that time, you could not throw a stone
into a Royal Palace without hitting someone’s
cousin, due to the tight network of familiar
relationships amongst rulers.
Carl did not stray from the norm and in 1896
he married his cousin from the United Kingdom:
she was Princess Maud, the daughter of King
Edward VII and his Danish wife, Queen Alexandra.
Alexandra was the sister of Frederik, Carl’s
father.
If this is getting confusing, here you can
feast your eyes with the family tree of the
Royal houses of Norway, Denmark, Sweden and
the United Kingdom, so you can have fun tracing
the blood ties amongst them:
I will post a link to the family tree in the
description below, it’s got thumbnails and
all for every member.
But let’s not forget about Maud.
She was born in London on the 26th of November
1869.
Since her early years, Princess Maud attended
regularly her mother’s family gatherings
in Denmark.
It was in one of such occasions that she came
to know her cousin Carl.
Their wedding was celebrated in Buckingham
Palace on the 22nd of July 1896, and the princely
couple settled in Copenhagen.
But Carl and Maud always kept strong ties
with the UK, and in fact their son and only
child, Prince Alexander, was born at Appleton
House in Norfolk, England, on the 2nd of July
1903.
Little did the young family know that their
lives were going to change drastically in
just a couple of years.
Haakon
On 7 June 1905 the Norwegian parliament, known
as the ‘Storting’ passed a resolution
to dissolve the union with Sweden.
The dissolution of the union between Norway
and Sweden was a momentous event which was
born from an apparently lesser dispute: a
conflict over the question of a separate Norwegian
consular service.
Norway and Sweden had their own cabinets and
parliaments, but shared a single head of state,
King Oscar II.
But Norwegians always felt like the lesser
party in the union: in fact they did not have
their own foreign service missions, and were
subordinate to Sweden in all matters of foreign
policy.
A new sense of national identity was brewing
in Norway and the Storting adopted a decision
to establish an independent Norwegian consular
service.
For those not familiar with the subtleties
of diplomacy, Embassies maintain relationships
with the government and institutions of the
host country, while consulates support citizens
abroad.
In practical terms, Norwegian expats and tourists
had to rely on Swedish consulates.
King Oscar II refused to sanction the Storting’s
decision.
As a result, the Norwegian Government resigned.
The King did not succeed in appointing a new
government.
This crisis meant that the union between the
two Scandinavian countries was no longer effective.
And that takes us to the 7th of June 1905,
when the Storting assembly unilaterally voted
for a dissolution of the union.
The Storting extended an offer to King Oscar
II to appoint a prince from his own House
of Bernadotte as new King of Norway.
This gesture of goodwill would have relieved
the tension now mounting between the two nations.
King Oscar, though, formally declined the
offer.
The Storting needed another candidate.
An early version of LinkedIn would have tried
to solve the issue via a mass mailing to thousands
of unqualified applicants.
But the Norwegian assembly was more effective
and turned to another candidate much closer
to home: our friend Prince Carl of Denmark.
He clearly fitted the job description:
‘Job ID #1: Norwegian King and Head of State.
The ideal candidate should fulfil the following
pre-requisites:
Male
Military officer, preferably in the Navy,
as they have the smartest uniforms
Scandinavian, familiar with Norwegian language
and culture
Related to the house of Bernadotte, for example
via his mother Louise, niece of King Oscar
II
With close ties with the most powerful nation
on Earth, the British Empire, for example
via marriage with a British Princess.
Must have already sired a son, to ensure succession.
Clean driving licence
Good Excel and Powerpoint skills not essential
but welcomed’
The offer was extended to Carl in Autumn of
that year.
The Danish Prince was not a power grabber
and had great consideration for the will of
the people.
He was well-aware that the majority party
in the Storting, the Liberals, were considering
the idea of making Norway a Republic.
So, he insisted that before accepting the
crown, he should listen to the opinion of
the Norwegian people: on his proposal, it
was decided to hold a referendum on Norway’s
future form of government.
The referendum was held on the 12th and 13th
of November 1905.
The result was almost 260,000 votes in favour
of a monarchy versus almost 70,000 for the
republic.
This gave Prince Carl a clear popular mandate.
On the 18th of November, Carl found in his
inbox a telegram pinged by the President of
the Storting, formally offering him the Norwegian
throne.
Prince Carl happily accepted the offer, announcing
that he would change his name into Haakon,
while his son Alexander would be known as
Olav, due to his love of the summer season.
The King’s choice of name was significant:
in Old Norse, it translates as ‘High Son’
or ‘Chosen Son’, and it had been used
by Norwegian kings centuries earlier, when
the Country was independent.
Haakon also adopted a personal motto: ‘Alt
for Norge’ or ‘All for Norway’.
A Chosen Son for an Independent Kingdom
On the 25th of November 1905 Norway’s new
royal family sailed into the capital Christiania
– later Oslo - on the naval vessel Heimdal,
named after the guardian God of Norse mythology.
Prime Minister Michelsen welcomed the new
king with these words:
“It has been nearly 600 years since the
Norwegian people have had a king of their
own.
Not in all this time has he been solely our
We have always had to share him with others
…
Chosen by a free people as a free man to lead
this country, he is to be our very own.
Once again, the king of the Norwegian people
will emerge as a powerful, unifying symbol
of the new, independent Norway and all that
it shall undertake.”
I so would love if this speech was followed
by knights chanting “The King
in
The North!
The King
in
the North!”
But it didn’t.
These were serious guys.
The speech was followed by a salvo of cannons
and church bells ringing throughout Oslo.
On the 27th King Haakon swore an oath of allegiance
to the constitution.
On 22 June 1906, King Haakon and Queen Maud
were crowned in Nidaros Cathedral in Trondheim.
Once again Haakon showed to be a king of the
people: well-aware that the custom of the
coronation was considered to be archaic and
undemocratic by many citizens, he opted for
a subdued ceremony.
For instance, the traditional lavish procession
previously staged by the Bernadottes was eliminated:
the King and Queen were escorted to the cathedral
in a single coach drawn by four horses.
The travel itself to Trondheim was conducted
with little ceremony by train and carriages,
with many stops along the way so that Haakon
and Maud could get acquainted with the people
of their new country.
Once they arrived at Nidaros Cathedral they
were welcomed by 2,300 attendees and by the
two Bishops who were to perform the ceremony:
Bishop Wexelsen of Nidaros, and the wonderfully
named Bishop Bang of Oslo.
That was his real surname, look it up.
Bishop Bang greeted the King with the words:
“May the Lord bless your going in and your
coming out now and for evermore.”
Very appropriate for Bishop Bang.
I will stop there before I am sent to Hell.
Immediately after the coronation King Haakon
immersed himself in Norwegian politics and
culture.
Polar explorer Fridtjof Nansen introduced
the Royals to the national sport: skiing.
King Haakon also started new traditions, such
as the much-loved annual children’s parade.
But besides these rare popular celebrations,
he and Maud showed great moderation, especially
in comparison with other royal families of
the time.
The Royal Court was small and expenses were
kept to a minimum.
This was yet another sign of Haakon’s political
sensibility.
Well-aware that more than 20% of the nation
had republican sympathies he felt it important
to maintain a modest lifestyle.
This moderation was also in line with Norwegian
tradition and respected the fact that Norway
was not a wealthy country at that time.
Today the country is the 8th largest producer
of oil worldwide and 3rd largest producer
of gas, but the first drillings were still
decades away.
King Haakon was also wary of respecting the
Norwegian constitution, to which he had sworn
an oath of allegiance.
He firmly believed that political power should
be in the hands of democratically elected
representatives, but he still wished to be
kept closely informed about political affairs
by the Government.
Although he might state his views on a certain
case, he always deferred to the majority in
the Council of State, unfailingly supported
policy decisions, and was careful never to
show an affinity for any political party.
During his first years on the throne, Haakon
oversaw important reforms, such as the institution
of universal female suffrage in 1913.
But a testing ordeal was just round the corner:
WWI.
The Neutral Ally
In the years preceding WWI, Haakon’s Foreign
Minister Jørgen Løvland outlined Norwegian
foreign along two directives: neutrality,
in combination with an active trade policy.
Neutrality eschewed political alliances that
might drag the country in foreign wars, with
the implicit agreement that Norway was within
the British sphere of influence.
The government expected the British Empire
to defend the young country in case of foreign
aggression.
When Germany declared war on Russia on 1 August,
Norway, along with Sweden and Denmark, issued
a declaration of neutrality.
The next priority for the country was to provide
supplies, feed the population and maintain
economic stability.
This led to a difficult balancing act for
the Norwegian government: on the one hand,
trade with Germany was vital for the country’s
economy; on the other hand, the UK pressured
Norway to become a part of the economic blockade
of Germany.
In the spring and summer of 1915 Germany started
to buy huge quantities of one particular supply
from Norway: fish.
Tons of fish, any fish related item they could
get hold of.
The result?
There was hardly any fish left for Norwegians.
Cod was out of stock!
Salmon was out of stock!
Haddock was out of stock!
Stock fish was out of stock!
[Caption: The Irony!]
Fish stocks were out of fish!
I think I made my point.
What little fish was available was incredibly
expensive.
In an attempt to quell exports to Germany,
Britain decided they would buy Norwegian fish
instead.
This decision decreased even more the availability
and affordability of a vital food supply,
while flooding Britain with stocks of Norwegian
stock fish.
In Autumn 1916 life was dire for Norwegians.
To continue with the fishing theme, they were
caught between a rock and a hard plaice.
On one side, the German Navy had extended
their unrestricted submarine warfare to the
Arctic Sea, sinking several Norwegian merchant
ships trading with Russia.
On the other side, Great Britain had imposed
an embargo on coal imports, as leverage to
prevent Norway from selling copper ore to
Germany.
Haakon and Maud were not oblivious to the
plight of their people.
In addition to conducting an even more frugal
lifestyle, the Royal Couple established a
fund to assist citizens in extremely difficult
circumstances.
Luckily for the country, the Norwegian and
British governments reached a deal, the ‘Tonnage
Agreement’ in February 1917.
This was a very clever set-up: first, Britain
would lift the coal embargo; in exchange,
Norway would suspend trade with Germany and
supply the Entente instead.
The Norwegian merchant ships would travel
in convoys protected by the Royal Navy, reducing
the risk of sinking by the Kaiser’s submarines.
The clever bit was that the agreement was
signed by the Norwegian Ship Owners Association,
which camouflaged the Norwegian Government’s
involvement allowing to preserve a formal
neutrality.
Hence, Norway became known as ‘the neutral
ally’.
The positive effects of this agreement, though,
did not reach all levels of society immediately.
In June 1917, ordinary citizens were still
struggling to cope with a cost of living that
had increased by 250% since the start of the
war.
Over 300,000 people took to the streets in
June to demonstrate against a lack of food
and money to pay for necessities – roughly
one seventh of the overall population!
The government did not fall, although this
crisis led to a radicalisation of the Labour
Party, whose members even considered revolution
as an answer.
Between Two Wars
Luckily for Haakon, the revolution did not
take place, rather an evolution of the electoral
system in 1919 which ensured a fairer representation
of the working classes.
Years later, in 1927, this reform led the
Labour Party to winning the majority at the
Storting.
In 1928, Haakon resisted pressures to form
a government led by the conservative ‘Agrarian
Party’ and respected Labour’s majority
by appointing its leader Christopher Hornsrud
as Prime Minister.
The conservatives were not happy about this
decision, but it would take only three years
for the Agrarian Party to return to power.
Amongst their ranks, a former military attaché,
now Defense Minister, became very active in
using the armed forces to quell union strikes
and keep the spectre of Bolshevism at bay.
His name was Vidkun Quisling.
I warmly invite you to watch our Biographics
episode about Vidkun Quisling, to learn more
about how he became the Nazi collaborator
by definition, a traitor of his own country,
the man who welcomed an invasion so he could
be Prime Minister.
Or
‘The Man Who Sold the Fjord’
if you like.
As a quick summary: Former Defense Minister
Quisling founded the National Union party
in May 1933, modelling it after the Nazi and
Fascist parties.
Defeated in two consecutive elections, Quisling
forged a friendship with Hitler’s advisor
Alfred Rosenberg and exploited these ties
to facilitate the German occupation of Norway.
But during the 1930’s these schemes had
not yet become a source of worry for King
Haakon, he had to face more personal issues.
On the 20th of November 1938, his beloved
Queen Maud died in London after a prolonged
illness, while visiting her British relatives.
Maud was buried in the Royal Mausoleum at
Akershus Castle.
Apparently shy in public, Maud was known for
being warm and vivacious with family and friends.
Her original personality set her apart from
other Queens of the time: she enjoyed outdoor
activities like riding or skiing, more than
court protocol, was a keen dancer and a competent
photographer, and was directly involved in
Prince Olav’s upbringing.
Haakon would surely have loved to have her
by his side during his – and his country’s
– darkest hour: the German invasion of April
1940.
The Voice of the Resistance
In our Quisling video we cover in detail the
invasion of Norway, the country’s resistance
efforts and its eventual liberation.
Today I will talk about the same events, but
from Haakon’s perspective.
An occupation of Norway was part of the III
Reich’s strategy, as the country could provide
the German war effort with iron ore and an
extensive merchant navy.
It would have happened regardless of Quisling’s
scheming to facilitate the German invasion,
hoping to be installed as Prime Minister.
German troops invaded Norway on 9 April 1940.
The heavy cruiser Blücher sailed into the
Oslo fjord in the early morning hours of that
day, transporting a landing force.
Their task was to arrest the King and the
members of the Government to compel Norway
to capitulate immediately.
But the Norwegians were no pushovers.
The Fjord was protected by the cannons of
the Oscarsborg Fortress, as well as the torpedo
batteries in Kaholmen Island.
They all opened fire on the Blücher and she
sank at 06:22am with 1,300 sailors on board.
The sinking of the Blücher delayed the German
troops’ advance on Oslo, giving the Royal
Family, the Government and the Storting representatives
the time needed to escape to safety in Elverum,
Eastern Norway.
There, the Storting gave the King and the
Government full authority to rule the country
for the duration of the war.
On the same day, Crown Prince Olav ensured
the safety of his family, by having his wife
Märtha and their three children cross the
border to Sweden.
They then travelled to the US in August.
Thanks to Martha’s friendship with Franklin
and Eleanor Roosevelt, she became a sort of
unofficial Norwegian Ambassador in Washington.
On the 10th of April King Haakon met with
the German envoy, Curt Bräuer.
The Germans demanded for the Government headed
by Johan Nygaardsvold to step down.
The King had to appoint a new government headed
by Vidkun Quisling.
The King put forth the German demands in an
extraordinary meeting of the Council of State
in the village of Nybergsund.
Haakon stated that he would not attempt to
influence the decision of the Government in
this matter, but that he could not comply
with the German ultimatum.
He would rather abdicate than have Quisling
as Prime Minister.
Without directly imposing his will, the King
had managed to influence the decision of his
ministers into rejecting Quisling.
Upon learning of the King’s refusal, German
forces repeatedly bombed Nybergsund, but he
and Olav managed to escape to safety.
On the 15th of April, the first Allied landing
party had arrived in Narvik.
A combined Anglo-French-Polish force would
support the Norwegian Army in engaging the
German troops.
But the Allies were ill-prepared for mountain
warfare and the Luftwaffe had complete air
superiority.
By the end of May, the British cabinet had
decided for a total retreat to avoid losing
the whole expeditionary force to the Germans.
King Haakon was left with a difficult choice.
Fleeing or staying?
Staying by his people would have seemed natural,
but the Germans were not hiding their intentions
to have him captured.
He could have been forced to provide legitimacy
to Quisling’s government.
In the end he decided to flee the Country:
he would establish a Government in exile in
London, from where he could denounce Quisling
or any other collaborationist cabinet, and
lead the resistance effort.
On 7 June 1940 the King, the Crown Prince
and the Government travelled from Tromsø
to England.
On the 9th, Norway had surrendered.
The Norwegians and their allies held out for
two months against a German invasion, longer
than any other country except for the Soviet
Union.
As I said: no pushovers.
From London, King Haakon became the foremost
symbol of the Norwegian people’s will to
fight for a free and independent Norway, and
his radio broadcasts from London served as
a source of inspiration for young and old
alike.
Back in Norway, the Germans had realised that
Quisling was an unreliable leader with little
popular support.
The reins of the country were effectively
taken by Reichskommissar Josef Terboven.
He attempted to establish a legal occupation
government, elected by the Storting, to collaborate
with the Nazis.
But this required the King’s abdication.
In a speech on the 8th of July 1940 Haakon
once again made clear that he would not give
in to German demands, and that he was still
the legitimate head of the Norwegian state.
On the 25th of September Terboven abandoned
all plans to collaborate with the existing
Norwegian authorities.
He declared the King and the Government deposed
and outlawed all political parties, except
for Quisling’s National Union.
All activities in support of the Royal Family
were forbidden, but King Haakon and the government-in-exile
stood firm in their resolve to fight until
Norway was liberated.
Over the next five years, Haakon’s speeches
would inspire daily, constant acts of civil
disobedience against the German occupiers.
Haakon’s monogram, a ‘7’ imposed on
a capital ‘H’ became a symbol of defiance.
Haakon also inspired the creation of the Milorg
– or Home Front.
This resistance movement was a constant thorn
in the Nazis’ side: it worked closely with
the Special Operations Executive and was responsible
for the destruction of the Telemark plant,
which stalled German research on the Atomic
bomb.
By the end of the War, Norway was garrisoned
by approximately 400,000 German troops, 1
soldier for every 6 citizens.
This gives an indication of how difficult
it was for the Reich to tame the Norwegians.
Did I mention that these guys were no pushovers?
Return of the Chosen Son
Germany capitulated on 8 May 1945.
Terboven committed suicide on the same day,
while Quisling was trialled and executed in
October.
King Haakon returned home on the 7th of June,
the fifth anniversary of his escape to London.
In late summer 1945 he embarked on a tour
of the country to see for himself the destruction
caused by the war, as well as to encourage
the ongoing efforts to rebuild infrastructure.
The Norwegians were happy to have their King
back, and grateful for his resolve during
the ordeal of the War.
A collection was launched to raise funds for
a special 75th birthday present: A Royal Yacht.
King Haakon accepted this gift in 1947 and
re-christened the vessel the Norge, which
he used in many official visits abroad.
Haakon continued to maintain strong ties with
the UK, even after Maud’s death.
During one of his visits to London, he attended
a theatrical performance of ‘The Moon is
Down’, by John Steinbeck.
The original novel was published in 1942 as
a means to encourage resistance in Nazi occupied
countries, and its setting, characters and
plot were based on the invasion of Norway.
One of the protagonists is the elderly, calm,
authoritative Mayor Orden, who encourages
his citizens to disobedience and open rebellion
against the invaders.
It is not difficult to find Haakon’s influence
on this character and on his opposition to
the treasonous shop keeper Corell, a Quisling
in disguise.
After 52 years on the throne, aged 85, King
Haakon VII died at the Royal Palace in Oslo
on the 21st of September 1957, and was buried
at Maud’s side, in the Royal Mausoleum at
Akershus Castle.
I hope you enjoyed today’s Biographics.
As a final thought, I will leave you with
Haakon’s dilemma: would you have stayed
in Norway, by your people, and risk giving
legitimacy – even involuntarily – to Quisling
and Terboven?
Or would you flee the country like he did?
And a small quiz for you: can you name an
European royal who decided to stay after the
German invasion?
Post your answers and opinion in the comments,
and as usual … thank you for watching!